[MUSIC PLAYING]
IDO GREEN: Hi, Ido Green
here, a developer advocate
for Actions on Google.
In my last video link
up here, I showed you
how to use a flashcard
card template to create
an app without any code.
Now, I'll show you how to use
one of our other templates,
the Trivia Game template
to create yet another app
for the Google Assistant.
In addition to showing
you how to build
an app with the template, I'll
show you how to test your app
and submit it for review.
To get started, open
the Action console.
Here, you can see the three
templates to choose from.
To select the
Trivia Game, simply
click on the Build button.
The next few steps are the same
for all three apps template.
You'll come to this screen
where you can customize your app
by choosing a personality.
Different personalities
have different ways
to presenting your
prompts and response.
They also have their own
music and sound effects.
Go ahead, click the Play button
to hear the examples of prompts
and choose the
personality that makes
the most sense for your app.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Click Next.
Now, we'll add questions,
answers, hints,
and follow-ups for
the game, and we'll
use a Google Sheets for that.
Click on Upload Content
via Google Sheets.
Click on the hyperlink to
create a copy of the template
we made for you.
You'll get a new browser
tab with this option.
Click on the Make a Copy button.
Now, here's the
creative part where
you could customize your app.
Make sure to change the
content on both the Questions
and Answers tab and
the Configuration tab.
The blue sections
should not be changed.
Add your questions
and answers here
and try adding fun
follow-ups that give users
extra facts about the answer.
If something is missing
or filled out incorrectly,
you'll get a
warning on the cell.
Once the Questions and
Answers Tab is completed,
click on the Configuration tab.
You'll need to change the
title and choose the number
of questions per game.
You could customize your app
with categories difficulty
and grade level, or
even custom audio
files to build your
own personality.
To configure a custom
option, type the key
and the value in the
Configuration tab
of your sheet.
Check out the description
for a link to configuration
parameters documentation.
You're now done with
the spreadsheet.
Copy the URL at the
top and paste it
into the previous screen in the
Google Sheet browser URL field.
Click on Connect.
Once your content is
uploaded successfully,
click on Create App, which
will close this wizard.
Congrats.
You've just finished
the hard part.
Getting creative with
your questions and answers
and other customization
make a fun,
engaging experience
for your users
and give your trivia
game a unique character.
Ready to test your app?
Let's take it for a spin.
Click on the simulator
in the left-side menu
or on the Test Up button.
Here's what the
simulators look like.
We'll focus on the left side.
The web simulator is a great
tool for testing your app
and seeing how it is going
to work on Google Assistant.
It's important to test that
everything is working well
before submitting
your app for review.
As you can see, you
could talk or type
to test your personality quiz.
By the way, if you logged
in into the Assistant
with the same account on
your phone or Google Home,
you could test your
creation there as well.
Once you've tested your
app, you're done building,
and it's time to move
on to the app preview.
Make sure your app follows
our Content Guidelines
and Best Practices link
below before submitting it
to Google for review.
If your app is approved, it will
be available to all Assistant
users.
To submit your app for review,
go to the Overview page
for your project in
the Actions console.
Click on the App
Information section.
Click Add and fill out
the requested information.
Most of this
information is public
and appears in the
Assistant Directory.
When you are done filling
out your app information,
you will return to the
Assistant app Draft Page.
You could skip the Location
Targeting section, the Surface
Capability section, and
the Account Linking section
by clicking Next.
Remember, template apps work
on all surfaces supported
by the Google Assistant.
Click Submit Draft for
review to submit your app.
That's it.
You're done.
Thanks for watching.
Check out the
YouTube description
below for links to
our documentation,
and be sure to check
out my other video
on How to Publish an App
for the Google Assistant
that Will Pass the
Review Process.
Until next time, be strong
and create amazing actions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]